you
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
Kern
melons leadership speaker series this is
number two on our schedule the first one
if you remember was there is canvas from
Westinghouse and today it's a great
honor and pleasure to have brought
Harvey who's the CEO of consol energy
but before i get to brett and consult
and the role they play in America's
energy future let me say a few words
about Carnegie Mellon the whole goal of
this leadership series is to bring
really thought leaders to campus and
create a forum for open exchange of
ideas between the thought leaders or
faculty or staff or students and alumni
and in the past we have seen some great
excitement in the process of doing so
where I have gotten emails after the
first leadership series from especially
students where they were really excited
that we were able to bring high profile
leaders to Carnegie Mellon so I'm hoping
that we will keep on continuing this we
do it once a semester so this is the
second one and if once a semester is too
few just let me know we can do it twice
a semester Michael Ransome is enough
time to schedule this more often sigh
today the talk is going to be on
America's future coal and gas in
America's energy future and energy in
this context is very significant for
Carnegie Mellon not just for the US but
for carnegie mellon over the last five
years or so we have made a conscious
effort to redirect our strategy of
investment towards energy and this is
before Obama was a lot good not that we
are geniuses but it was clear to us that
there is going to be a problem
especially when it comes to the
interaction of energy production growth
economy and the environment and in that
context we started investing in a whole
bunch of areas but especially in the
area of renewables and in carbon
sequestration as a point of history you
had our energy work in this university
mainly in the Department of Engineering
and public policy and
engineering and somewhat and chemical
for the last 25 to 30 years in fact ed
Reuben out here I hate to tell you how
long he's been here but he came here and
he was telling me that he was working on
Carmel issues and integrated models of
energy production when it was not very
sexy and nobody wanted to fund him and
now he has sent money away because he
can't spend it fast enough so that's how
important energy is to Carnegie Mellon
and we will get to do you in a second in
the last 12 months we've been creating a
strategy for developing what we call the
energy futures Institute this is not
futures like futures in on the stock
market this is the future of Energy
Institute as the right way to think
about it and we are trying to build this
on three pillars the first pillar is
transitioning to a lower carbon
sustainable energy future and the
implication of that is that coal and gas
are going to be here for a very very
long time so the goal is not to get rid
of them but the goal is to find better
ways to make them more efficient and to
also start integrating renewables the
second pillar is going to be smart grid
because without that you can't integrate
the renewables and the third pillar is
going to be innovation in the area of
energy and this is where we've created a
great partnership with any TL over the
last four years as Scott Clara who are
introduced after Brent speaks has been a
great partner from any TL so Scott thank
you for being here today so let me now
get to the topic of today's conversation
which is consults energy approach to
powering America and coal and gas for
the future just a little bit of Arkansas
I'm sure bread is going to tell you a
lot more than I would but it is the
leading diversified energy company in
the US and one of the top diversified
fuel producers in the eastern US it
helps generate two-thirds of the
nation's power supply and mine's more
high quality bituminous coal than any
other US producer it is one of the
largest
natural gas exploration companies with
nearly 13,000 producing walls and it's
also a leader in industry innovation
developing techniques that enhance the
safety and productivity in coal mining
to operations for operating the largest
private R&D facility devoted exclusively
to finding cleaner more efficient ways
of producing energy and this great
company is led by a great person his
name is Brett Harvey he's the CEO and
chairman of consol energy and prior to
joining consult he was the president and
chief executive officer of pacific core
energy which is a subsidiary of pacific
or located in the western part of the US
right and the California region he is a
fourth generation coal miner and he
began his career in 1979 with Kaiser
steel company as a long wall supervisor
supervisor at the company Sunnyside mine
in utah by 1984 so this is 1979 so 1984
he was elected vice president and
general manager and the reason i
emphasize these dates is for the
students in the audience this is a good
goal to keep five years from the day you
start at some low-level to vp of the
company i think that should be the goal
and for professors of the audience and
the idea is how do we teach our students
to get there that fast he's received
several awards let me just mention one
which is the person nickels award which
he received in 2003 which was jointly
conferred by the Society for mining
metallurgy and exploration inc and the
american society of mechanical engineers
for notable scientific or industrial
achievement in the field of solid fuels
a native of utah brett holds a
bachelor's degree in mining engineering
from the University of Utah I can go on
and on but let me just hand it over to
Brad and let's see what he has to say
welcome sir
we're going to show a quick film and
then I'll get going here
progress man
cole makes it possible
conditions of poverty stagnation and
the modern era dawn in the fashion
electric spark when I realized that what
burns but coal creek CA
the straight revolution oil fuels the
moment
which a modern world exists
technological advances unimaginable 100
years ago solar and wind off a promise
but the promise of the color was pink
head right now today
in every developed and developing nation
on the face of the earth
the equation is simple electricity heat
light and security
right or well and did a measurably
better quality of life
electricity to energize the world
call the power of now
I am coll hi hi ho I am home I
thank you it's good to be with you
picture's worth a thousand words and
those are pictures to bring back what
got us here today and I think it's
important that we understand where we
are today versus where we're going thank
you for the opportunity to be in here to
speak to you I hope its stimulating and
it gives you some ideas ok there we go
I'll get this figured out here in second
consultant energy was organized just
before the Civil War what I like to ask
is what were you doing that and if you
think about it we are just the stewards
of these resources over time stewards of
Technology stewards of the resources
tours of of who we are in life and so
I'm the steward of consol energy at this
point in time I'm very proud of that
we're the largest underground coal
producer in the East largest gas
producer in Appalachia natural gas and
and we've emerged as a leading
diversified energy producer because the
energy is right here under our feet and
that's what built this nation now the
history of coal very diversified if you
think about I'm a fourth-generation
minor I have many relatives that went on
before me that passed away in the coal
mines because safety was an issue we've
gone beyond that consol now is at the
point to where we expect nobody to have
an accident at any time in our minds
ever zero is what we believe in so what
we're driving for we lead the industry
and we believe it's just a matter of
time and we believe we're the generation
that will take it to zero for the next
generation to work and extract energy
for society with zero accidents not zero
fatalities zero accidents and we really
believe we can do that and we're heading
that direction now let's talk about our
resources but you this is a great
stratigraphic column of when you look at
the earth look at all the pay's owns in
terms of energy that is right beneath
our feet we have the coal seams the more
shallow areas and the most dominant coal
seam is the Pittsburgh eight coal seam
which created and fueled the Industrial
Revolution one of the strongest steel
making cities in the world was
Pittsburgh and it was fueled by this
cold right here if you go deeper you got
conventional gas which has been drilled
forever when I say forever in the last
hundred years in this area and now when
you go deeper seven
thousand eight thousand feet you have
the Marcellus Shale and other shale
formations that Harbor gas which is good
for society going forward anywhere you
drill in western Pennsylvania northern
West Virginia eastern Ohio you see the
same stratigraphic column of value and
what a great resources is for this
country going forward to energize our
lives and make things happen okay why
would I be talking about energy if I
didn't think it was a gross business it
really is a growth business when you
look at the world itself and by the year
twenty thirty five we expect the energy
and the end o entire world the appetite
to increase by fifty percent and in the
United States only ten percent when you
think of only ten percent the United
States here's what we're looking at
we're looking at energy a well developed
country that is use it just using
incremental energy as they learn to save
energy and be more productive with the
energy they have versus nations who
don't have any energy and we'll talk
about that in a minute but look at the
growth cycle it's amazing how much it
can grow and how much energy this world
needs going forward now where is the
booming demand we've all hear about
China we all hear about India as these
countries industrialize this the energy
is going to be driven for the knee per
capita person by these these places now
how where we're going to get this energy
and what form is going to take a lot of
debate going on about what energy we're
going to use is a carbon does it nuclear
I mean all that debates going on but the
reality of it is the entire world needs
this energy and they need that fifty
percent more energy in the next 25 years
where is it going to come from
well let's start with coal massive uses
in the right now is happening in the use
of coal worldwide China India are
expected to be the two largest growth
areas and continue to be the two largest
growth areas but it's going to
exponentially accelerate especially in
India China is already on that path in
India's right behind it you have
Indonesia and other places like that
same trajectory you have problems like
we saw a nuclear in Japan that looks
like it's going to shift them for demand
for coal in the short term more coal so
what is really going to happen in the
world and where is the demand going to
come from and what are the capabilities
of world to produce this energy versus
other forms of energy well let's talk a
little bit about natural gas we always
knew the shale was there we always knew
that we have gas in the shale we didn't
know how much we never had the
technology to extract it because of
great engineers we figured out how to
drill vertically and then drill
horizontally and frack the zones to
release the gas out of the shales and
now it looks like we probably have at
least 30 times more gas in the United
States and we thought we had as little
as six to seven years ago how think
about that when you have this huge
reserves of energy that has now been
able to be tapped the world energy has
started to change and sort of shipping
our dollars overseas we need to learn to
extract our energy right at home now
when you think of marcellus shale and
you think of shale plays in this area
think of it in terms of embryo it has to
be born it has to be educated has to be
clothed it has to be fed has to be all
of those things before it's a player so
it's just on that we are just at the
beginning of the marcellus age in terms
of what can be done in terms of energy
for the United States but in terms of
Western PA this will be as important to
Western PA as steel was in the last
century that's how big this fight is
that's amazing and the demand in the
United States for low-cost energy is
well as domestic energy or red white
blue energy is certainly there now i'm
going to dis is a little bit
controversial but i believe this with
all my heart I think that everybody in
the world deserves a right to have some
access to energy how is it human right
it's not it's not a legislative right
but I think it's human right and if they
have the access they have a better
childhood they live longer they have
cleaner water they have a better form of
education and there's over almost 2
billion people in the world that don't
have access to energy right now but it's
changing because the technology of the
human society has changed at a point
where information being spread to people
who don't have all of these things but
wanting sex and in some cases is
creating revolutions and we will see
that these forms of energy need to be
accessed and what I believe and consult
believes it's a basic human right to
have access to energy and the two lowest
cost access into energy in the entire
world or coal and natural gas other
forms of energy at a higher cost level
now we need to figure that out as a
society or maybe you need to figure out
the student how to make the cost
structure of different forms of energy
drop to those levels but until that
changes that's the reality of where we
live let's talked about the excess of
the coal right here in Pennsylvania
where is going today down in Green
County we have a mind called to Bailey
mine it's a largest exporter of coal out
of North America into China right now
right here within an hour's drive and
it's making steel in China with Chinese
steel mills just like it did here in
Pittsburgh a hundred years ago so you
can see how it's involving Europe has a
need for energy South America has a need
for energy steel mills are being built
all over the world for the industrial
revolutions in other countries and they
need these resources
to go so that creates an opportunity for
console to supply coal not only to the
to the local markets but also around the
world okay what about opportunities for
natural gas like I said we think we have
as much as 30 times more gas than we
thought we had five and six years ago
now natural gas how important is it is
twenty percent of our electricity it
heats most of our homes it's a huge
value to the United States to anybody
that has natural gas and we found 30
times more it could be in exported only
five years ago we thought we were going
to import most of our natural gas now we
think we're going to export most of our
natural gas and it's all based on a
change in technology access right under
our feet to natural gas that could be
extracted before with the same
technology we've used for a hundred
years in terms of vertical fracking we
just learned to how to frack it
horizontally what an amazing change it
and these things were developed with
engineers trying to find oil in the
Gulf's and so forth we applied it to
natural gas and it's working very well
so we could be an exporter not only of
coal but also of natural gas going
forward because its energy demand
worldwide is a common leveling for all
humanity if everybody needs it the cost
structure will move once this energy
hits the water whether it's coal and
vessels natural gas get gas and vessels
or oil and vessels it'll move around the
world at very low cost
now all this creates environmental
issues anytime you extract something
from the earth York you're affecting
something else and so you have to what
we have to follow the regulation of wood
which were under budget federal
governments and the state governments
but what I've learned is every
generation makes it better if you go
back into the 90s we are now burning in
the United States 1 billion tons of coal
a year for our economy that has doubled
over the last 20 years and the emissions
other than co2 itself the emissions of
mercury knock socks and all of that has
dropped sixty percent because of changes
in technology and demand by our by our
society to make coal cleaner sokol has
actually become cleaner and we're using
twice as much as we were 20 years ago we
lead the world in terms of technology
and how we use coal now when you hear
people talk about Cole they don't talk
about in that context they talked about
coal is what our grandparents did or
what the last generation did I tell you
Cola is an energy sources of future now
what we'll do is learn to burn it
cleaner was much better technology
coming from schools just like this and
that technology I'll think about it the
United States has thirty percent of all
the world's coal energy it has fifty
percent of the best economic coal in the
world so for us to be debating whether
we're going to use coal or not is
absolutely throwing the baby out with
the bathwater so to speak it is not
something that we should do and seventy
percent of that coal is owned by the
federal government which means it's
owned by us as citizens so for us to to
look at this resource and lock it up and
not use it for the good of society is
absolutely the wrong thing all we need
is technology and that technology is the
burnet cleaner to sequestered carbon and
do all those things that create a lot of
value for society
how regulation I'd say I think when we
talk about regulation sometimes we live
in a society where were so far ahead
there are regulations burden what we've
been doing and it drives a cost up and
I'll give you example the cost of a ton
of coal seven years ago and the United
States was about thirty dollars a ton
the cost of a ton of coal today is about
sixty dollars a ton and rising and it's
because the cost of regulation is rising
now are we making a better
environmentally sure we are are we
making a tough around the economy to
compete worldwide we are so that new
technology that we're talking about has
to be competitive and it has to be with
natural gas and with cold because of we
take these valuable resources we lock
them up and then try to compete with the
rest of the world all we do is drive the
price of what we're doing up and that
and that's an important thing to
understand
now let's talk about energy policy our
country does not have an energy policy
has not had an energy policy and i would
say in some senses it's almost been an
anti energy policy in terms of we
haven't focused on our own resources and
applied technology for the good of the
citizens what we've done is put
regulation after regulation on top of
what was already in place made it more
expensive and we have a very scattered
energy policy in fact our energy policy
would almost look like countries who
don't have any energy domestically if
Japan had our resources they would
conquer the world just with their own
industry but they have to import
everything that they have and we have it
right here under our feet but we debate
whether we want to use it or not so the
energy policy policy of the United
States has to have and embrace
technology and fossil fuels to move
forward if we don't do that we're
leaving all that valuable energy on the
ground and we're taking away our edge
compared to the rest of the world in
terms of competition so that's got to be
addressed
we really knew need a real portfolio of
energy choices now it took us two
hundred years ago where we're at in
terms of energy we went through the
Industrial Revolution where we're at
today think of all the things you use in
your life that use energy the heater
your home the charging of your
electronic products the movement of your
cars all of those things take energy and
if you change the value of that ten
years ago the value of a car coming off
of the lines of Detroit the twenty-nine
percent energy if you looked at all the
energy processes in making the steel and
extracting all the processes if you
change that very much you make that car
so it's never competitive against with
other countries so if you double your
cost of energy you're going to you're
going to drive the cost of that vehicle
up and that's just on a that's just what
we looked at in terms of a vehicle what
happens to every product you have so we
got where we are because we use what we
had we had fossil fuels we invented
nuclear energy there are issues around
that renewables are on their way but
what I'm telling you today is it takes a
combination or portfolio of all these
energies to based on where they're at in
the world and what technology is
available if we don't do it that way if
we choose one over the other we will
fail or drive our costs out cost
structure out of the way we didn't get
where we're at in this world because
we're stupid and forest and put
regulation on top of it that doesn't be
rational about what's really in place
and what the value of these things are
eventually will hurt us
see I'm going to get the back yes here
here's some conclusions I want to leave
with you safety is the number one value
of consult we shouldn't be attracted
anything without the safety of the
people we have 9,000 people working
every day we expect no one to get hurt
but we expect them to produce the
largest amounts of energy in the use of
United States fossil fuels our own will
continue to be essentially for the
quality of life that we have today so if
you expect your quality allows to stay
the same you're going to have to use
fossil fuels but we should be smart
enough to use them in a different way
just like just like we had distributed
distributed coal and everybody's house
one generation ago now it's centralized
somewhere else and now we're going to
learn to capture the carbon out of it so
every generation is going to make this
better but we have to have access to
electricity I believe is a basic human
right consol itself is perfectly
positioned to respond to the marketplace
and take advantage of what we have today
and it's right here under our feet it's
an amazing story of what's actually in
the in western PA fossil fuels can and
will be and find ways to be used more
environmentally safe because that got
fossil fuels has got was to where we can
make those decisions today domestic
energy policy should embrace fossil
fuels for the good of the people as well
as a good of the economy and the good of
the environment they all have to be tied
together that's why we need an energy
policy that addresses all of these
together and the last thing I want to
leave with you is we need all forms of
energy but i believe probably the most
important form of energy is the human
energy and that goes right back to the
safety part should would be doing any of
this if anybody takes any risks or
should we apply the human energy that we
see at this university to solve all
these problems you use all the resources
we have and I think it's important
because if we if we push some of these
resources aside we're only hurting
ourselves
and our ability to compete worldwide so
I thank you for the tongue this time I
hope I have stimulated some thoughts for
you and please feel free to ask some
questions when we're ready thank you am
I going to take your seat of the podium
Brett will be joined by our panelists
and as soon as I introduce our panelists
will be ready for Q&A so in the meantime
be thinking about questions let me start
with Scott Clara who's one of our
panelists today he's the deputy director
of any TL which is the National Energy
Technology Laboratory located right here
in our backyard called South Park
Scott's been there for 25 years he's had
25 years of diversified experience in
various companies and what I didn't
quite get it is he was seven years at
AT&T and I'm trying to figure out how
did AT&T lead to any TL but one of these
days I'll ask him that question and he
was also at calgon carbon corporation
he's been at any TL for more than 20
years he has a BS and ms from university
of pittsburgh in chemical engineering
and also in petroleum engineering one of
the things i could tell you about Scott
I kind of mentioned that in my
introduction of bread but about four
years ago Scott Clara Anthony cugini
Andy government and myself I don't know
what is it that we were drinking
basically cooked up this any TL are you
a partnership and Anthony then became
the director and Scott became the deputy
just about a year ago so Scott is now
leading that partnership / so thank you
Scott for all your support next one in
line is dr. edward rubin and rubin who I
kind of alluded to early on he is the
alumni professor of environmental
engineering and public policy in the
College of Engineering at Carnegie
Mellon and Ed has been here for 30 plus
years focusing on the area of
environment and energy and many many
different aspects of that it serves on
several committees but the most notable
one
is the one that he's serving on right
now which is the NRC committee studying
climate change mitigation policy energy
R&D planning and alternative
transportation technologies and heed
also was one of the lead authors of a
chapter in the famous IPCC report that
won the Nobel Prize with Al Gore what
did Al Gore do in that report I guess
nothing I thought so but I thought I
might've checked last but not the least
as the calvin gregory calvin reeder oh
there he is he's an assistant professor
of civil and environmental engineering
he teaches a course in environmental
microbiology for engineers and fluid
mechanics and his research lies in
biotechnology biogeochemistry with a
focus on the interaction between
microorganisms and geochemistry which
influence the fate of environmental
pollution his one of his research
projects is actually the Marcellus Shale
so with that in mind let's open the
panel to questions and answers since do
I see any hands rising out there okay is
it a good question okay since there are
several questions out here I think I'll
hold off on my questions yes sir go for
it we have microphones to hear over here
okay Joyce comments take the microphone
on my loud they are loud enough and in a
good way I noticed you talking about the
health benefits of cold its verdict has
the highest spot fine particulate matter
collision and I was willing what the
coal industry was doing try to offset
some lose some other issues I guess
that's a brat right it clearly is a
functional combustion and if and I
talked briefly about it when you look at
couple generations ago everybody had a
gud furnace in their house and went to
natural gas then we distributed the
generation then we put scrubbers on the
power plants and now we're looking at
particulate matter beyond that and I
think it should it's a function of the
natural capital solution as we demand
more from our resources and demand more
about our clean air there'll be a
solution to that the particulates for a
matter of filtering it as it comes out
and there'll be another wave of that and
there's typically done by the utilities
now when I talk about health as a
relates to the use of energy it's
clearly been proven worldwide that the
use of energy per capita creates a much
healthier society and is there an
optimum level sure there is do we get
better every generation that's true so I
think the particulates are somewhat
related to colburn as well as
transportation of automobiles and our
society we need to address all those so
Scott let me follow up on that question
let me ask this question you lead a
large research operation at any TR
barely that is focused on better
utilization of codes can you tell us in
the context of what Brett was talking
about it is dog and this question of the
supposed what are the research issue is
that any TL is looking at that's going
to help us get to a better future I
think historically and inbred address
some of this that are the technologies
for things like knocks and socks and
even particulate matter that you
mentioned now there are technology sets
out there that can do a tremendously
good job because he indicated that coal
uses up emissions are substantially down
and that technology is it can get better
and better in this bread mentioned there
are cost trade-offs in etc that are used
with those technologies and historically
in any TL we were key in developing
those technology sets relative to coal
currently the key issue on our plate
right now
is really co2 and so we're in the
process of developing Suites of
technologies around the terms carbon
capture and storage and some of you that
are familiar with it it will ring true
and with carbon capture and storage the
big issues are that you can capture co2
from coal burning energy facilities
right now but it's very expensive and so
we're looking at revolutionary
technologies that will drive that cost
down to a reasonable acceptable value on
storage side we're looking to identify
storage opportunities geologic
sequestration is the key storage
opportunity right now relative to safely
sequestering this co2 for potentially
forever and so we're looking at
identifying those sequestration
opportunities as well as developing all
the imaging tools and computer modeling
tools res more simulators to ensure that
it's safe and secure and so that's
really the current thrust relative
dekole research at least within our
facility oh yes
counting my just returned from a trip to
the Amazon rainforest
I saw firsthand the massive
deforestation of the Amazon River from
three quarters so what concerns me is
that these forests they mitigate carbon
dioxide and my deforestation and my
grading of clothes which beats the loss
of habitation we are not only creating a
loss of biodiversity because of please
celebrating that
now my blood in cold and increasing
these green outcast offenses how can the
address this problem of preventing
deforestation the same time we're using
the level of carbon dioxide well I think
I'll give you a technology answer and
then we could open it up and Brett and
others can give you some different
perspective but I think the bottom line
is there's no silver bullet so when you
look at mitigation strategies for co2
all of those things play a key factor
and it's important into the future if
there are future carpet constraints that
it's going to take truly this technology
set combined whether it be going to
renewables whether it be looking at coal
with carbon capture and storage looking
at for Station agricultural procedures
process these technologies things such
as that and it really will require every
one of those to be pushed pretty hard to
make it all work let me go to Edwin and
you work in the carbon sequestration
area for some of the decades now and
I've heard now seven times and co 2 2nd
sequestration of amazing portal
technology so can you reflect on how far
can we go what is the future of cold and
how far can you lose you lose
illustration both in terms of getting it
out of the atmosphere and at a
reasonable price which is due another
softball question for maybe we should
talk first about the future of coal we
do a lot of modeling work here I don't
know if you all know
we have a crystal ball that forecasts
the future of coal with 100% accuracy I
consulted it late last week the answer
is and I'm sure this is going to be true
coal use will continue to go up or down
or stay about before it is now that's
that's the answer we got a number of
factors will determine how how that
plays out and what the role of this
technology is actually in the last
couple of years we've seen coleus go
down and co2 emissions in this country
have gone down but it isn't the way we
would like to have it that's what cars
are the economic turned down we don't
want to reduce you to emissions by by
putting people out of work in hand and
slow it down the economy so one of the
key factors that certainly will affect
but we'll go in this country let me talk
about this country as opposed to the
worldwide it was we get some questions
is how quickly the economic recovery
proceeds in there there's a lot of
uncertainty in when we'll start to see
them upward arrives at co2 it could be
as recent as early as next year might
not occur for ten years depending on the
convocation quote whatever happens the
role of technology for coal use and for
other energy forms that cold competes
with this could be rather rather
critical the carbon sequestration
technology that that Scott just talked
about today would add considerable cost
to the power plants that would use it
ooh by the time you roll that in
late payers would see a much smaller
amount but over time it would rise so
how that plays out remains to be seen it
depends on how aggressively rd budgets
are and what kinds of regulatory pushes
there are that are reasonable and can
help promote technology innovation as
opposed to unreasonable in ways that
would would stifle those things but also
depend a lot on the price and cost of
other alternative energy systems natural
gas right now everybody is very bullish
on it well hope that happens but we have
seen bullish times in the past perhaps
quite as polishes as now but things that
that turned around so depending on how
that plays out how the nuclear power
industry in this country reacts to the
unfortunate events in Japan all of that
will affect that considerably how close
to zero we can get pretty I think we can
thermodynamically get pretty close but
maybe not quite all the way okay so we
get a nettle epsilon and make it a story
so let me actually breast talking two
components colon gas or that rose
getting hands being raised up there
ready to wake you up are you going to
ask for coal or gas okay go for the last
of a gas hi my name is felling i'm on
the PhD student
I'm hearing public policy and I think
we've heard from to the other panelists
and off the third tip are another
instance and you just complain you are
getting soft balls there's perhaps more
of a hardball question if you've given
your expertise were to have an extended
discussion with Brett on perhaps one of
the things he said in its presentation
that maybe you don't disagree with but
you just want to have an extended
discussion on what might that be we
already started that discussion just
before it will be hukka us all help us
more first question was how deep are
your pocket sorry yeah it really has to
do with the pace of innovation and the
role of regulation in society so there's
the old adage about where you stand
depends on where you sit and not
everybody in this room sits or stands
necessarily the same place but we all
sit in this country and the trick is to
get that it's the Goldilocks moment just
right balance so i would i would push on
consol and others who are producers of
co2 to be a little less patient and a
little more aggressive in both funding
and participating in the research that's
going to be needed to develop the kinds
of technologies that will in fact the
future of coal will depend
so I think it's the rate of change issue
that will be talking about the other
thing I'd probably welder I just have to
find some opportunity to say it and even
with my good friends will do reseting
extra tend to use this word clean
unclean energy in a variety of ways so
one thing I didn't hear in and bretts
talk and a lot of other talks is more
about the one form of energy that i
would consider the only real clean
energy if clean means the absence of
environmental impacts I don't think
anything we do on the supply side being
cold nuclear renewables would be my
definition of clean mr. the only clean
energy i know of is the energy we don't
use and don't need so let's not forget
that it's our demands for energy that
really drive everything on the supply
side and let's not forget there's also a
lot of room and a lot of opportunities
for reducing the needs for energy while
not sacrificing the quality of life that
we all aspire to so energy efficiency
energy conservation really ought to be
the first thing that occurs to us when
we think about clean energy bank said
let me try to change the conversation of
gas because that was the second part of
bread stock so this is an IT person how
good to you guys inside run and to write
a from that so run around an IT person
information
so just that the question asks just put
in that context as if it's a dumb
question but so let me start with if i
look at the cost of reducing energy from
coal or gas i think clearly on a per
unit basis call as much uber today than
gases and then i'm told that we have
about 250 years of code and about 100
years of gas based on the new finds so
I'm trends and I've also told that until
gas comes talk about six dollars per
unit or something my bad it's not
economically feasible to produce energy
on a profitable basis I'm trying to
figure out why are we even talking about
gasps when we have 250 years of call
those are you breath okay well you can
see I have a split personality on that
but I i would say that we think as it
comes to electricity itself gasps had
traditionally been about three or four
times the cost of coal and because of
the change of regulation we see that the
next round of generation in the United
States will be gas generation that's
part of the reason we got back into the
gas business because we saw that as the
next round Cole still has some
technology issues to overcome in terms
of how we deal with co2 and how we deal
with particulates that we just talked
about on other things we think after
about five to seven years Cole will come
back with some new technology and that
technology will drive another round of
what I we would call future Jan coal
plants coal plants that have near zero
emissions but until then I we think gas
will fill fill the void and the end
that's and the cost structure but the
cost structure will drive the cost of
electricity up because that coal is by
far the lowest cost
fuel in the world and in the United
States okay so we'll come to that
senator let me get to Calvin Gregory
who's other panelists let's not spoken
as yet turns on equals and Marcellus
hasn't counted help me understand or
help us understand if we were to go and
track all the shale gas what would the
big issues be and how can we do that in
a sustainable manner that kind of make
sense for the environment and also from
economic basis well so as as we just
talked very briefly that it's really
about that cost cost per unit extraction
is really going to be one of the big
drivers for development of the Marcellus
one of the major costs are the potential
for environmental externalities and in
particular the the management of water
hydraulic fracturing uses a few million
gallons of water which know maybe 10 or
30 percent of it flows back to the
surface containing a lot of minerals
that dissolved from the deep subsurface
into that water and that high tds that
its salts and metals are are difficult
to manage the technology that that came
to the Marcellus from the development of
Barnett Shale down in Texas largely
largely relied on on just disposal in
deep well injection and Texas had fifty
to eighty thousand deep well injection
sites where as Pennsylvania has about
seven and so there is a question of how
do you manage that water and the unique
infrastructure of Pennsylvania's unique
water needs have even rise to solutions
that address both the the environmental
impacts of Marcellus Shale Davone but
also some of these cost issues that are
going to be key to its development and
that is
the technology that is reuse of flowback
water for subsequent hydraulic fracture
this both minimizes the potential for
environmental impact and that cellular
trunking water around or potentially
disposing these things in publicly on
treatment plants or dilution and so
forth but also reduces the costs
associated with development because this
is water that now does not have to be
treated and disposed of so you can
greatly reduce not only the amount of
water that's extracted but the amount of
water that needs to be treated and and
thereby disposed producing road traffic
and so forth so this is the kind of
technology that is evolving from the
unique geology and geography and
infrastructure of Pennsylvania that's
enabling the Marcellus to be developed
in a sustainable manner noise so this is
a question there
more on his recent reports that the
natural gas burns much more between
club winning Sharpe Michelle
as large of an impact on the gene pool
look at the same thing has a lot higher
didn't have time to change that the co2
but one shorter as well but that
environmental benefit is equal we're not
there and cold is cheaper
destructibility
that's like this go get
the attraction to
you make a good point that study we
questioned some of the science in that
study but we're looking at we have our
own R&D department we're looking at it
just to make sure every extraction
process has a footprint but when you
look at the co2 and if you look at what
the federal government's driving in
terms of co2 release per unit in a power
plant it ignores some of the things we
saw in that study and it really drives
economic decisions towards producing
electricity directly with it's picking
fuels based on regulation rather than
using reason in terms of economics and
then I would rather be on the side of
doing the right thing but sometimes
regulation gets ahead of the science of
it and there is an impact putting
pipelines in and so forth and and we're
seeing that Western PA now there's a lot
more to come with that just like there
was an impact of the steel business and
and all that has to evolve but but it
really is going to take both these fuels
I think to make a good balanced
portfolio but for the right reasons to
that lets it was a question that this
summer yeah great when I stabilized firm
let me add something on a talk show feel
when it comes to carbon capture and
storage technologies they're often
thought of as a coal solution but the
reality is it's a co2 solution and so
the technology sets that are coming out
of coal for capture for example many of
those are completely applicable to
natural gas fire electric generation or
other natural gas usage and as well as
on the sequestration side I'm molecule
of co2 is a molecule of co2 if you have
a secure storage site and so the bottom
line is when we talk about ccs
technologies I think a key is not to get
coal centric at the bottom line is that
same technology set would almost surely
be deployed to natural gas fleet of
power plants into the future as well and
that will obviously all depend on
any timing and severity of any drivers
to do that so again just that point
their dad as well the done same
technology sets important to natural gas
can i yes let me just add a comment to
me to the question on the life cycle
analysis I've it I will agree
wholeheartedly with with breakfast it's
the study from Cornell that's gotten a
lot of attention in the last couple of
days I've been involved in some other
study of natural gas resources where the
same issue has come up and what I've
learned is that there is a terribly
small amount of data associated with
those methane readings from gas
production there's a lot more effort
going into trying to refine that the
studies I see no even accounting for
those data as reported by the EPA on a
lifecycle basis that gas still comes out
ahead of cold when gas is used in an
efficient new power plant and there's
still a difference having said that if I
put even today's clubman captions in
frustration plants on a coal plant in
fact coal is cleaner than gas in terms
of its carbon emissions three or four
times cleaner so ultimately for either
gas or coal to be viable in a world
where our goal is going to be to reduce
our carbon emissions by something like
eighty percent by the middle
to me into mix of this century both of
those technologies will need to capture
and sequester carbon on that basis they
look as as green as just about many of
the renewables or nuclear thanks and any
other questions is that a quick
follow-up because then there's a Western
follow because I'm come back as much of
a policy question that environmental
question like already make the decision
marcellus shale well
to actually make that investment
decision definitely building when the
national policy will be four years
there will be no policy 20 years from
now just like today well Armand actually
a Marcel as well has a payback bunch of
liquors on a cold a cold investment
almost years quicker and so the gas
decision really is one that's driven by
diversification as well as the access
that we didn't have to the cast and so
there is a real demand for natural gas
that's not for cold and we'll fill that
market with it with that so that's an
economic decision the coal markets are
really driven by what are the power
plants want to do and what's the airport
capability but a coal mine takes almost
seven years to permit and in that
investments way out there versus gasps
Oh gasps is much closer rising on terms
of return on investment so you got to
remember one of the things that at least
I read in veteran breads car it's not
just about co2 reduction it's also an
energy security as in we spent a lot of
money setting it across the pond it's
places that are not very friendly to us
and we are making them wealthy to come
back at us right so I think that was the
other point in here I thought at least I
was there yes yes you are gonna be up
and when we want to integrate more let's
say what generation we move faster
rapping generation in order to balance
it which is given with them to gas but
too cold yeah like what they're not able
to read this book how much is that the
impact your decisions ain't goin torkoal
orgasm we consider that we want to
right for every for every set of wind
generation there has to be a gas back up
and so that's one of the reason we got
into the gas business because we knew
that backup would be in place when the
wind does it blow people still want that
electricity and if coal is at a base
level that's always running which is
typically the peaking system has to be
when wind is not operating gas has to
fill it and because the demand when you
hit that switch you really expect it to
be there and guess so our model shows
that every time you build a win package
you have to put a gas package right
behind it for one of the winds not
pulling stories is ok we can debate that
but we don't have enough time right now
so i'm told that bread does have a
scheduling this train dogs yet but i
think we would stay within two or three
more minutes maybe no more than five is
I don't get right that's fine any yeah I
was going to ask so we hear a lot about
gas here especially because of Marcellus
and it's going to create huge advantages
to the United States but there must be
shale gas distribute all around the
world nobody's had access
for so whatever competitive advantage we
have is going to be very short how much
is it out there in the rest of the world
and how long will take preventive and
start pumping it as fast as we do well
our competitive advantage really is cold
okay because of cost structures the gas
side because of the finding of shale gas
Europe is now changing everybody who has
shales are now changing their economics
Europe has always been held hostage
because it ran out of kool-aid minded
out they went to Russian gas Russia use
that as leverage politically at a
neckline economically on Europe now they
found their own gas they're using as
leverage back so though the whole
world's changing on this gas issue where
you're going to use gas where are you
going to use coal if I'm up and the deep
hinterlands of China or India and I just
want electricity I'm going to go to coal
first and i'm going to i'm not worried
about what we're talking about I'm want
electricity and that remember that's two
billion people and they also read all
this off the internet because they have
internet even before electricity it's
interesting how that works but these
people want what we have and coal is
going to be the pace driver of that and
so Cole really is the the common
denominator of humanity in terms of
energy and then the rest of it is
technology to make it better for
everybody so there's an interesting
that you bring up in Africa I know there
are places which have cell phone access
but no electricity and there's a
business in taking your South when it
taking 30 miles away that is charged and
bring it back and people are actually
making some good letting knowing that
the keynote I think we heard discussed
about the regulations were being imposed
and but elsewhere in the keynote there
was a figure buck sixty percent more
efficient or or there was something
about the effectiveness not to reduction
for the compliment right well I guess is
it possible look back in terms of
historical ease up and make some kind of
reasonable judgment about the
regulations the effective regulation for
the event is that good or that bad so
that we can talk about regulations
these these are experts here on the
regulation side and how to deal with
that I'm just going to say from a
business perspective regulation I think
makes us better every generation I just
wanted to get to the point to where it's
so far ahead of us that it hurts us and
that's the concern from the business
side you might want to address the
technology versus regulation yeah
they're there is a lot to learn I'm
going to let ed and maybe Calvin make
some comments but add for sure relatives
technology wise to looking back at
learning curves for analogous technology
types and us learning from that and
maybe even accelerating or definitely at
a minimum understanding when
technologies at a given point in time
could potentially be ready and available
so we do look back historically at these
learning curves and try to relate it to
the state of development that we have
today in determining what a technology
might be available and it happens to be
an expert in that area looking at these
past learning curves on the technologies
and yeah historically it depends on the
time frame our roads look we've done for
example a number of detailed case
studies over the last 30 years on not
co2 but so2 sulfur dioxide was a major
her gluten first to be regulated in
nineteen i started in 1970s it led to a
technology that is now widely deployed
on our plants called scrubbers or flue
gas desulfurization systems the bad news
was that initially those costs went up
considerably higher than what had been
anticipated
Systems just didn't work the industry
didn't understand the technology didn't
understand a lot of chemistry of details
and then by the time that we had a more
expensive system and the good news is
that those expensive more expensive
systems did a great job of capturing co2
the way meant overtime once a market was
established competition already
substantially lowered the price of
costume that of these technologies such
that with him timeframe of about two
decades the cost was half what it was at
the beginning almost back to the early
levels so it all has in their number of
other industries that have similar kinds
of kinds of history's one of the areas
where we didn't see that innovation in
this country was in n.o X control we
didn't have stringent regulations for a
new x japan did and then european state
and that's where the technology that we
wand of mine twenty years later was
originated so the other message is that
the companies that that innovate tend to
be market leaders that tend to bring in
wealth to the country and what we're
trying to figure out Mallory's what's
the stress right great in in terms of a
whole variety of things we can do in the
carbon front to get a similar positive
result thanks i know that's a really
interesting topic which is a little off
regulation and policy and innovation
then you can talk another two more hours
on that issue with having said that I
know we are running a bit late and that
has to leave so please join me in
thanking breath